do you believe that Trump violated the
peaceful transfer of power a key
principle that of American democracy
that we must uphold are you in high
school
where do you go to school you go around
here uh Vermont I live in New Hampshire
oh okay so you've been from Vermont well
thank you for the question so here's
what I know
if this election is about Biden's
failures and our vision for the future
we are going to win if it's about
relitigating things that happen two
three years ago we're gonna lose and so
by the way all Ron DeSantis is doing is
relitigating covid and talking about how
he was so much better than Trump on
covet so even so he's already lying